you think this is the first time  someone's held a gun to my head you're  gonna make me laugh look miss unknown is  calling again and what would make you  think that unknown is amiss  or the packages  what's this you should go out in the car  all of you now  no one's getting out of the car now  tries seat belting out  perhaps we'll work together again in the  future  that's no kind of us house the  Mediterranean bank has been robbed  before but never like this the driver  he's known as the transporter we will  make him pay  may I be of some assistance  you and your friends took something from  me and I've taken something from you  I'll give you 12 hours to find your  father  before I kill him I mean it because if  you insult my dad so we're going to see  carousel do we have a choice  no really  is coming  we're gonna need more men  what took you so long  a couple of babies had to put a thing